[MUSIC PLAYING]
JORGE CUETO: Everyone,
welcome to talks at Google.
Today, we have Amanda
Bradford, the founder and CEO
of dating app the League.
The League is a dating
app that combines
data and social graphs from
both Facebook and LinkedIn
to offer privacy from
coworkers, more context
about a potential match,
and a curated community
of ambitious singles who desire
an equally driven partner.
Amanda previously worked
in technical roles
at both Salesforce
and Google and holds
an MBA from Stanford University
and a BS in information systems
from Carnegie Mellon.
It's a great pleasure for us to
have Amanda here with us today.
AMANDA BRADFORD: Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
JORGE CUETO: So to
get started, maybe
you could tell us a little
bit about how you came up
with the idea for the
League, because it definitely
has a unique spin
on the dating app.
AMANDA BRADFORD: Yeah, I
drew from my own experiences,
I like to say.
So I kind of followed
your classic design
a product that you want
to use, and don't really
listen other people, and
then kind of figure it out
once you launch it.
So I was at Stanford Business
School, which is obviously
a very selective community.
It's a pretty intense
admissions process.
I think I planned
for about two years
on, like, how I was going
to get into Stanford and all
the things I needed to do.
And so you could argue, like,
the longer prep time you have,
the better your application
is for business school.
And so I think part
of what inspired me
around this, kind
of taking that model
and overlay it onto the
dating community, is, A,
how effective it was
in matching people.
I think Peter can
talk to this, too.
Our class, I think we had,
like, 20 or 30 couples that
just formed in the first month.
And you're kind of
like, what is it
about this community that kind
of creates a way that people
can kind of feel
connected faster?
And I think it is because
people did put their best
effort into their profile.
They worked really hard.
They made sure their
photos were good.
They put their application
in, and they waited.
And then when they
join the community,
they're there for
the right reasons.
And they have kind of
the right-- you know,
they're going to their class,
and they're taking notes.
And it's sort of like
they're good students,
because you put all
this time into it.
And so I think that's
sort of the concept
I want to take into
dating, because I
think dating suffers
from people having
a lack of a kind of
intent or motivation
to have a really core kind
of relationship-seeking
experience.
There's a lot of
these casual apps.
So I wanted to kind of take what
I learned at business school
and how Stanford did
such a good job of kind
of creating this diverse but
very interconnected community.
And how could I create,
like, a digital version
of a business school?
And so I think that was sort of
the kind of high-level vision.
And then, of
course, it gets down
into the nuts and bolts of
execution, which is not--
you can't always execute things
the right way, the perfect way,
on V1.
So I think we're kind
of working towards that.
But, yeah, so that was, I
guess, the impetus of me.
I was single.
I was in business school.
And I was like, I want
this app because I
want to save myself
time and bad dates
and terrible conversations.
So I was optimizing kind of
for myself, I guess, selfishly.
And then I found myself
writing feature requests
into, like, Hinge, and Coffee
Meets Bagel, and Tinder.
And I was literally
writing them,
like, what I thought
they should do.
And then I remember I
googled all the founders.
And I was looking
at their background.
I'm like, wait a minute.
I'm more technical
than all of these guys.
And I, like, worked
at a tech company.
These guys had come
from finance and stuff.
I was like, why am I writing
them feature requests?
I was, like, writing
specs for them.
And I was like, I'm just going
to go and build this myself.
So I kind of talked myself
into going and starting
this project, instead
of kind of complaining
about how much dating apps
suck all the time, which I was.
JORGE CUETO: Yeah,
that's awesome.
So what would you say is the
one differentiating feature
from the League that sets it
apart from other dating apps
out there?
What would you say
to someone who's
maybe using Tinder or Bumble?
AMANDA BRADFORD: I always think
our three core pillars or value
proposition is, one,
we just give you
much more context about a user.
So we have your LinkedIn.
We're pulling your LinkedIn
data and your Facebook data
and your kind of League
data that you give us.
So you just know more
information about the person,
like, step one.
And then step two, because
we pull that social graph
from work and your social life,
so your Facebook friends, we
actually block you
from what I think
are awkward and unnecessary
interactions, to be, like,
matched with your
colleague on a dating app
when you're working on
a project with them.
That's just, I think,
an unnecessary thing.
And we don't need
to do that anymore
because we have the social
graphs at our disposal.
So I think setting
up that privacy
so people feel like it's a
very safe place, that they can
be single, and they don't have
to worry about kind of bleeding
into work, and then the last
piece is that community aspect.
I think having a community where
people, whether or not they
are that, they
are self-selecting
into a community that is for
an egalitarian relationship.
They are kind of stating
somewhat that they are open to,
you know, a power couple
relationship or a relationship
where both parties are equal.
And so I think creating
a community where that
is the ethos and the values.
And maybe not everyone
upholds them all the time.
But if that's kind of
part of the table stakes
to even get in, I
think that's sort
of how you create a really
good value system and community
like a Google.
You know, Google has a
great internal community.
So I always kind of think
is I want to create,
where all the people
that use the League,
it feels like a
bunch of Googlers.
And they're all debating around
how we should kind of dictate
the community or
what rules we should
put in place, what governance.
And I want the community to be
involved in those decisions.
I don't want to be, like, a
big brother, where we're like,
here's what you need to do.
And you get kicked
out if you do this.
I want it to be
kind of democracy.
So we're kind of
focusing on how do we
build the social
aspect of the community
so that our users can help
us with some of these harder
decisions about when
do we kick someone out?
Or when do we let that profile--
you know, is that League-worthy?
And what are we
calling League-worthy?
And as we kind of
talk about a lot
of these existential
questions, we
want our users to
feel involved, as
if it's their
community that they're
getting to have a voice in.
JORGE CUETO: The
definition of what
you consider to
be League-worthy,
has that changed over time?
AMANDA BRADFORD: Yeah,
I like that word.
We came up with that
word because, I think,
it's purposefully ambiguous.
But I think what we've seen
is, yeah, it definitely has
changed, definitely by region.
So you go from New York,
where almost half your users
are in finance or tech
or media, basically.
And then you go to somewhere,
like, we just launched Houston.
Oil and gas is the
number-one industry there.
So really understanding,
we had a whole table
of kind of classifications
on programs, schools,
and different jobs.
For instance, Comcast in
Philadelphia is like the Google
there.
Like So we had to kind of
re-rank and recalibrate
a lot of how we thought
about sort of selection
and what we were
using as our proxy
because if you think
about it, we're
copying the Google
playbook, which is use GPA
as a proxy for intelligence.
I remember when I first
started at Google.
Half my friends were like,
I don't have a 3.75 GPA,
so I can't apply.
And Google's line
was always like,
we know that GPA is a stupid
indicator, but it's a proxy.
And it's not a bad one.
And I remember when we did
the case study on that.
I was like, I think
that's what we do.
That's what we do with kind
of education and profession.
We know it's not perfect.
There's definitely a lot
of other things and factors
to evaluate, but it's a proxy.
And it does a pretty good,
like, 80% of the job.
And I think that's where the
kind of fun, exciting part
is, where you get
the humans involved.
And we can kind of build a
perfect solution next to it.
JORGE CUETO: What are some
of the factors that you take
into account for determining
whether someone should get
approved or not, besides GPA?
AMANDA BRADFORD:
We don't ask GPA.
But we have their
LinkedIn profile.
So you can see what
institutions they have attended,
and you can see
what jobs they've
held, what titles they've
had, the progression
of their titles.
You can kind of see.
You get a decent
indication of if someone
is relatively ambitious
from their LinkedIn profile.
So I think that's sort
of one thing we look for,
is just sort of that.
I kind of think of the League.
It is a little bit of
a workaholic community.
Everyone in it, they're working.
Work is one of their passions,
and that is a shared value that
is shared across the community.
So I think one of your
questions was about, like,
screening based on values.
But I actually would argue that
the people who join the League
value education.
They also value
ambition, and they
value people going after
and accomplishing things.
And so I think to
me, we've kind of
created one of the few
value-based dating communities,
rather than kind of the
Walmarts of the world, where
they're just sort of people.
So I think we've kind
of tried to embed
the values into our brand.
JORGE CUETO: And then one of the
other things that you mentioned
is your experience in
large tech companies
is sort of what made
you realize, hey.
If all these other
people who didn't
have technical background could
do it, then I can also do it.
So maybe could you
share a little bit
about how you drew on your
experiences and the skills
you developed while working
at Salesforce and Google
to help you when you
started your company?
AMANDA BRADFORD: Yeah, I mean,
I think the three key skills
I learned were sales.
Starting a company, I
would say the first two
years is, like, 90% sales.
And then the second two years,
I feel like maybe 70% sales.
But for the most part, you're
moving into a sales role
essentially when
you start a company.
So I think having a quota,
having learned how to sell,
having learned what it feels
like to miss your quota,
what it feels like to do
really well and go to a club,
and kind of understand how
kind of the sales mentality
works I think is super
helpful, because when
you start your company,
you're pitching investors.
You're pitching employees.
You're pitching senior leaders.
You're pitching partners.
So you're always pitching.
You're pitching people
to join your app and say,
this is where you're going to
meet your significant other.
So I'm pitching users.
So I think having that sales
experience was super helpful,
and I think it allows you
to kind of learn how to be
confident, even if you're not.
So I think when I was
at DoubleClick, well,
I was at Google.
But I was selling
DoubleClick for Publishers,
which if any of you guys know,
is a very complex product
and has a lot of legacy.
There were actually
two products happening
when I was selling it.
So I was selling XFP and
DFP, depending on what
use case the publisher needed.
And it was a lot of hand-waving.
That's a very complex system.
So you had to learn
it inside and out,
and then be able to answer
all the questions about it,
and then also be able
to pitch it in a way
that made the development team
or whoever your buyer was sign
the check to actually
implement the product.
So I think at Google,
especially at Google,
I got very deep into kind
of the technical, like,
understanding how the
algorithms work for forecasting.
So I think getting
into the weeds
and getting experience really--
I remember reading a spec
at Google that I was like,
this is so over my
head, because it
was about kind of all
the math equations that
go into the actual
forecasting of the ads,
of if they were going to
run out of ad inventory.
So it's a very complex system.
But I think getting
experience, getting
super deep and technical,
even if you're not
the technical person,
but being able to wrap
your head around it, because I
think that allowed me to have
the product management skills
that I could kind of go
and design these really complex
systems and manage people,
implementing them, and not kind
of get over my head, I guess.
So I think learning
how to kind of digest
large pieces of information
and understand it and be
able to explain
it back to people.
JORGE CUETO: What
would you say was
the hardest part of the process
of starting the company?
Was there anything
that maybe was
harder than you expected
before you went into it?
AMANDA BRADFORD: Yeah, oh,
everything, yeah, everything,
across the board, I think
for me, I waited a long time.
I wanted to really make sure
that the-- because you asked,
like, when did you want
to start a company?
I was like, I was
just building an app.
I built an app that
I wanted to use,
and then I wanted to see
if there was a potential
to be a company.
Did we have a business model?
Were people going
to spend money?
I didn't know that.
For a while, even
before we monetized,
we didn't know if we just had,
like, a nice, little lifestyle
dating app.
Which who knows what's
going to happen?
But we didn't know if people
were going to spend money.
So you kind of don't know
the value of your asset
until you monetize.
So I think that was
something I wish we
had done a little bit earlier.
I think I would have taken less
dilutive funding and things
like that because we would have
realized that our users are OK
paying and have the
kind of income to pay.
So we sort of kind of
delayed our experimentation
on monetization a
little bit late.
So I think that was
something that I
think would have made it
easier because we would
have known that, OK, we can
expect this amount of money
coming in.
So we don't need to be running
as fast or as stressed out.
We kind of all thought we
were running out of money
for, like, the second year.
So we were just
like, oh, my gosh.
Let's work 100 hour weeks.
So I think my other
takeaway was just
hiring a little bit earlier.
I waited a very long
time because I wanted--
before I recruited
amazing people like you
guys from your amazing
jobs at places like Google,
I wanted to make sure that I had
a real kind of compelling pitch
to convince someone
to join my team,
that we're not going
to go under in a year.
I'm going to be able
to pay you market rate.
So I wanted to kind
of be in that position
to hire really amazing people.
But because of that, we're
just now kind of getting there.
So for three years,
I basically was
running all the departments,
pretty poorly, I would say,
you know, at a B, B-minus level.
So I was doing marketing.
I'm doing design.
I was doing, like,
the ad creative.
So I think that was
the hardest part,
was just being kind of a
one-man show for too long.
JORGE CUETO: So out of all those
functions that you took on,
which was your favorite?
Is there anything that
you enjoyed in particular?
AMANDA BRADFORD:
I realized this.
I love copywriting.
So my future dream job is
that I get to just do, like,
the fun copywriting
for the League,
and everybody else can
do all the other work.
So, yeah, I think you learn
a lot because you're--
you kind of think of it
as you're all over the--
if you think of the
company as, like, a stack,
you're moving across the stack.
And you're doing
email marketing.
Then you're doing Facebook ads.
Then you're figuring out
how to set up HR and Zendesk
and get the support
team to integrate it
into Slack so that people
can open a JIRA ticket.
So it's like you're doing
every job in the company.
In some ways, it's
awesome, because you
get to really know what your
strengths and weaknesses are,
really obviously, because
you're like, whoa.
I'm actually really
not good at design.
That was not a good logo,
so I'm really glad we
didn't go with that one.
But I worked on the logo for
probably, like, 40 hours.
And then finally my
friend was like, I'm just
taking this off your plate
because yours are not good.
But learning that,
right, and so now I
know that I need to have a
creative director that I always
run stuff by.
And she has a really
good eye for this.
So I think you
start to recognize.
Especially when
you're young and you
think you're good at
everything, I kind of
learned what I wasn't good
at and who I needed to hire.
So I think in some ways, it
was helpful to kind of do
everything because
then I was like,
these things I'm really bad at.
I'm not very organized.
So I'm actually not a
great product manager.
We just hired a PM, and
he's really organized.
So he's going to complement my
more sporadic style of PMing,
I guess.
So I think it's kind of
recognizing your holes
and trying to find people
to complement them.
JORGE CUETO: What
advice would you
give to someone who is currently
at a big company, who's
maybe interested in
starting a company
or on the fence about it?
AMANDA BRADFORD: So I was you.
And what I did is I did
this, like, weekend,
weeknight incubator
when I was at Google.
And my boss was cool.
She let me leave
early on Thursdays.
I think I had to get down there.
It was, like, one night a week.
And then I think the team
could meet on the weekend.
But it was a good kind
of jumping off point,
like, dipping your toe in
the water of entrepreneurship
because it was, like,
a 12-week program.
The idea was at the end, we
kind of do a pitch night.
And you decide if anyone's
ideas kind of have legs.
And people vote on them.
And then some of the teams
stay together and work on it.
Some don't.
But I think, given that you
guys are not at graduate school,
like, there's a lot of
project courses there.
But there are some that will
be in San Francisco or Mountain
View that can kind of
serve that same purpose.
And I think that
was helpful to me,
because that was my first
foray into realizing that--
I was like, oh, I
actually don't have
that many skills to
bring to the table
because we were a group of four.
And I wasn't the one
building the website.
I said I was going
to be the designer.
And that was when
I first started
realizing that I wasn't as good
at design as I thought I was.
But I think you
kind of learn how
to go through the motions of
a startup and kind of what
the really annoying and
hard parts are going to be
and what the fun
parts are going to be.
JORGE CUETO: And one of
the ways that you can grow
is, as you mentioned, by moving
into new markets, new regions.
So I read recently,
I think on Forbes,
that you guys are
moving into Houston
or have recently
moved into Houston.
So how did you decide that
that was the right time
to move into that market?
AMANDA BRADFORD: Well, you
brought up a good point.
It was how do you grow without
reducing your selectivity?
One way to do that is to kind
of move to different cities.
So you keep New York
as what New York is.
You keep them well.
And then you go
and launch Houston,
and you're selective in Houston.
So that's one way to grow
that we are working on now.
So we've launched 20
cities this summer.
So that's, like, one growth
channel, is just city launches,
letting our users
know we're there.
Once they use the app,
share at a higher rate.
So honestly, opening cities
is one of our key growth
strategies.
And then I think
the other one will
be trying to understand
how to grow virally
within a specific community.
So within Houston, we
have, like, a ton of people
from Deloitte.
I think we got the whole Houston
Deloitte office or something.
So it's like, how do we--
but we don't have a ton of
other sign ups in Houston.
So how do we kind of smartly
and automatedly go and say, OK.
You have a ton of
Deloitte people.
How do we maybe create a
Deloitte promotion or some sort
of-- you know, leverage
that kind of core network
you have to get the
eccentric people.
So I think we're kind of trying
to now think a little bit more,
how do you take
grassroots strategy
and automate it into your
sort of launch strategy
and your launch marketing?
So that's what we're
kind of focusing on now.
JORGE CUETO: Do you have
any specific changes
in terms of your overall
product vision or maybe
some key features
that you implemented
that changed the way people
use the app now compared
to when you first started?
AMANDA BRADFORD: First
and foremost, we'll
always be kind of just
improving the core product value
proposition, which is we are
going to deliver you someone
that we think you'll
be compatible with.
But the stuff that I'm
really excited about that
isn't as revenue-generating
and kind of viral
but that we're excited
about is we're creating
a singles map, anonymous.
But this has been
my dream since--
we just didn't have the
development team to do it
when we launched the League.
And it was a little
bit of a side feature.
But basically, the idea is let's
say your friend is recently
out of a relationship,
and it's Friday night.
And you want to take
her out, rebound,
go out and, like, drink and
meet some nice, single people.
So you're like, where do you go?
And in San Francisco,
that's a very hard question.
You're like, there's
nowhere to go.
Where are the single people?
So basically, what we
want to do is allow people
to kind of refresh
the map and then see
where-- you know, if all the
single people are at-- what
is the one in Mountain View, the
big bar you guys always go to,
the Google bar?
Sports, yeah, so if
everyone's at Sports Page,
then you could see that
on the map and be like,
maybe Sports Page is a
good Friday-night spot.
So I don't know.
We'll see how it goes.
We're kind of
MVPing it right now.
But I think the idea
is I want to increase
the efficiency of just
the whole problem, which
is, A, single people don't know
other people are single, right?
So that's sort of why I love the
slap bracelets that we always
do, because it's like when you
wear a glow in the dark slap
bracelet, you are single.
So you're not going to have
any of the kind of accidental
you're hitting on someone who
has a boyfriend or a girlfriend
or something like that.
So I personally want to add more
clarity and transparency and
efficiency to the process.
And I think our users
are smart enough
to kind of figure
a lot of stuff out.
It's just like we're
trying to remove
kind of the noise
and the clutter
and help them get
to the end goal
faster, which is meeting
someone offline that you fancy.
JORGE CUETO: The
map feature sort
of reminds me of the
new Snapchat map, yeah.
AMANDA BRADFORD: I know.
Well, I mean, I'm not a Snapchat
user because I'm too old,
I decided.
I was like, Instagram,
I'm stopping at Instagram.
But I just looked at
the Snapchat feature,
and it's very similar.
We want to keep ours
anonymous, of course,
so you're not like,
that's really creepy,
to be like, that match
didn't like me back.
But he's over here.
You don't want people to
have too much information.
But I think just getting
a high-level understanding
of where your kind of nightlife
is going on in your city.
And then I think
then, to me, this
helps us move into more of a
social-networking-like vibe
and aspect.
And then if you can have people
who aren't single and single
just using the app as kind
of a nightlife radar app,
then I think it becomes
a lot more interesting.
And we can start to think
about can we actually become
a social network?
Or are we always going to be,
you know, a dating service?
JORGE CUETO: Yeah, so I think
in San Francisco's case,
there are single
people out there.
But a really hard part of the
process is that everyone's
so busy that--
AMANDA BRADFORD: They're
all at SoulCycle, man.
JORGE CUETO: --it's really hard
for people to align schedules
to meet up.
So I think that
anything you can do
to make the process of actually
meeting up more seamless,
I think that would be great.
AMANDA BRADFORD: We
invested a lot in events.
We have actually another feature
that we're coming out with is,
like, a fully
aggregated event feeds.
So right now, we
just kind of hand
pick cool events in
our cities that we
think are on brand and cool.
But instead, I think as we
think about moving into more
of a utility and trying to be
a social network that people
actually depend on and
use on a weekly basis,
then we want to start getting
into understanding kind
of where the user is,
why they're opening
the app at that time, and
what kind of their use case
is at that moment.
So we don't want to get
into, like, the Tinder,
like, I'm looking for tonight--
where do I go tonight--
thing.
But I think of it as
more of, like, events.
If I can meet
three of my matches
by going to the Tipsy
Pig on Friday night,
and I don't have to
have a 1 and 1/2,
like, awkward
Starbucks interview
meeting with three people
during my workday, to me,
that's way more efficient.
I got to kind of meet them
in a more fun environment.
Maybe I hit it off
with some of them.
Maybe I didn't.
I got to talk to them
for 5 or 10 minutes.
Maybe I like all three of them.
But I think to me, like,
kind of moving group,
like what Grouper
used to do, which
was a competitor that died,
but they set up three people,
three guys and three girls.
And people actually
really liked that.
I remember when I was
doing user research.
People liked the concept.
There wasn't a lot of retention.
They had a retention problem.
No one did, like,
a second Grouper.
But there is something
there, I think,
with not requiring everyone
to go to these one-on-one kind
of interview-style dates.
And if we can kind of
change the format of dating
and make it more group and fun
and oriented around values,
or hobbies, or yoga,
or people with dogs,
or whatever it might
be, I think that to me
that's a much more efficient way
to date and to meet new people.
JORGE CUETO: What would you say
is one feature that the League
offers that a lot of people
don't know about that maybe you
wish they knew?
AMANDA BRADFORD: Well, I guess
I would say, a lot of people
know about this.
But Googlers hate this feature
because it basically blocks you
from all your Googlers.
We use LinkedIn.
JORGE CUETO: And
there are so many.
AMANDA BRADFORD: I know.
Well, basically, Google
and Facebook hate us.
And everyone else
is like, thank you
for not matching me with
my coworker in the cube
next to me.
But, yeah, I would say
that feature is probably
pretty hidden.
Because we ask you to log
in with your LinkedIn, which
people think is kind
of weird, it actually
allows us to then block you
from anyone who works with you
or anyone you're connected to.
So I was in sales.
So I was always friending
people on LinkedIn,
and I did a lot of, like,
business development
on LinkedIn.
So the last thing
I wanted to do was
see one of the people
I was kind of doing
business deals with on my feed.
That's weird.
So I was like, let's just
prevent that situation.
So I talked about
that a little bit.
But that one not
everyone knows about.
And then I would say
you can also sort.
So I come from the
CRM industry, right?
So when I look at the
match screen of the League,
everyone's like, there's
so much data there.
And I'm like, well,
as a CRM person,
you want to see all of the
information kind of condensed
in, like, an executive summary.
So if you look at
our match screen,
I'm, like, the only one on the
team that likes that screen.
But I like it
because it shows you
all the information you need.
And you can actually sort
your matches by least flaky,
most popular, most recent,
and then your best match.
And a lot of people
don't know that.
But the best match algorithm
is actually pretty good,
and no one uses that, either.
So those are the
under-marketed--
I would call them under-marketed
features in the app
because we haven't done
much to kind of tell
the users about them.
JORGE CUETO: In terms of
the League sort of brand
that the League
has, do you think
that that could
potentially also lead
to maybe inadequate matches?
Because I think
that a lot of times,
people might find that they're
really compatible with someone
who doesn't necessarily come
from the same, like, high-level
social class background
that they do,
that there's cross-social-class
relationships.
AMANDA BRADFORD: Well,
statistically, that's not true.
Like I always like to
say, everything's a proxy,
and your V1 is never
going to be perfect.
So you have to just ignore
some of the outlying use cases.
It's like product
management, right?
So that's sort of the
way I think about it,
is that I looked at
statistically who is
getting married to each other.
Similar age, similar
education level, and actually
similar industry is
highly significant.
So I guess you can either
try to go with the data
or go against the data.
But I think for
us, if it's already
happening in the
real world, we're
just trying to create a software
platform that facilitates that.
We're not trying to sort of--
I mean, eventually,
yeah, maybe I
do want to change what people
are doing in the real world.
I think that's when you
start to have influence.
When you're a
company like Google,
you can actually start to
really make change in society
and how people are
using software.
But I think at
our stage, we just
want to be able to get to
that point and give our users
what they need, what they're
kind of coming to our door for.
So I don't know.
I guess I look at
it as we're kind
of using math and data to
give you kind of the best
probability of someone
you would match with,
and we're not kind
of trying to change
the data set that we're using.
We're trying to use the data
set that people have researched
for 20 or 30 years and apply
it in, like, a smarter way.
So eventually, I want to
have my own research team
and kind of maybe debunk some of
this stuff or find out how to--
you know, I think we
always talk about that.
You know, the creatives that
never meet the finance people,
how do we make sure that
they're both kind of coming
into the community
on equal amounts?
And it's a challenge.
We have way more
finance people coming
into the New York community
than creatives or people
on Broadway.
I think that's just, A, a
fact of New York population
but, B, a little bit
of a fact of life.
And it is going to
be harder for that
match to happen in
the real world, too.
So shouldn't it
be kind of harder
for it to happen
on a dating app?
So I don't know.
I guess we try to
think that we're
kind of mimicking the real
world and making it more
efficient and useful and
not trying to kind of tell
people what they
should or shouldn't
be doing at this point.
But we do kick people
out if they're bad.
So we do make sure
people are respectful.
So that's one thing we're
pretty hard and fast on.
But as far as whether they're
swiping or being super picky,
I mean, we give them advice.
But if people want
to be picky and say
no to every single person we
give them for a whole year
and then complain, you
can't please everybody,
as you guys know.
Product managers, you
always have that email
that keeps you up at night.
And we just had one.
It was actually a
72-year-old lesbian woman
who was very mad at me
because we didn't have anyone
to give her.
And we refunded her.
But I did research.
And I was like, what if we
did an advertising campaign
to get--
and then I was like,
this is not-- you
know, at the end of the
day, especially when
you're running a company,
you've got to cut that 20% off.
I cannot be worrying about the
72-year-old lesbian right now
when we have 30-year-olds
maybe running out of matches.
That's way more
critical of a problem.
So it's all kind of triage.
And I think a lot of the
questions that go into
things we want to do when we
have more people on staff are,
yes, educating people on why
you should be open-minded
and why you shouldn't reject
people when they're 5'
9" instead of 5' 10".
And I have a lot of, like,
blog posts saved up in me
that I want to help
people kind of to optimize
their dating life.
But first, we've got to
kind of get the product out.
JORGE CUETO: In terms
of growth, another one
of the opportunities
could be expanding more
into the LGBT community.
So have you thought
about ways to do that?
What's the
distribution right now?
AMANDA BRADFORD: We do.
We have a great LGBT
community in New York
and actually a really
good one in London.
It's weirdly disproportionate.
But we haven't done
any targeted marketing.
It's been all word
of mouth through that
because actually on
Facebook, you can only
target straight people.
Or they make you have a
separate campaign for each one.
So that's been a pretty
viral community for us.
So, yeah, I think as
we think about where
to spend in marketing, it's
definitely investing in LGBT,
I think, because they
also spend a lot, too.
So I would say our LGBT
and the New York finance,
they both are kind of one
of our better customers.
So we definitely want to learn
how to kind of market to them
and acquire them more scalably.
JORGE CUETO: I want to
go back a little bit
to the filtering by
education level and job,
because something I
was thinking about
was that you're
using this as a proxy
for determining whether someone
is driven, right, in some ways.
But there's cases
where people could
be driven or really
passionate about something,
but don't necessarily
have the education level.
AMANDA BRADFORD: Right,
it doesn't come out, like,
on paper as much.
JORGE CUETO: So potentially,
you could be an artist,
and you're really
passionate about that
and are a great artist.
But in terms of
education and job,
that might not be
shown in your resume,
or you might not
have a LinkedIn page.
So have you thought
about other things
that you can use as proxies
to get at that sentiment?
AMANDA BRADFORD: Yeah, we
talked a lot about that
because LinkedIn is
going to become--
right now, LinkedIn is fine.
And it's sort of serving
as a natural curation
mechanism for us because if you
don't have a LinkedIn account,
you drop off at that point.
So we almost didn't even have
to deal with the people that
don't have LinkedIn accounts.
But a lot of those
are creatives.
And so when we launched
LA, we had a big problem
because a lot of people
in LA don't use LinkedIn.
It's kind of not cool.
If you're a cool
person in the industry,
you're not on LinkedIn, really.
So we ended up
building a new flow
so you could pay to skip it.
And then for LA,
when we launched,
we ended up kind of
comping a lot of people
to get through that kind of
original LinkedIn screen.
I think as we think about
international, that's
going to be a huge
issue for us, too,
because not everyone
internationally
is kind of as LinkedIn focused.
It's very white collar.
So as you get into kind of
the creative, the producers,
they're not on there.
They might be on IMDB.
So we talked about
Amex has an API login.
So we're kind of brainstorming
with some different ways
to kind of start to get outside
of our core LinkedIn, like,
white collar demographic.
But I would say
that LinkedIn does
have a pretty big audience.
So I think for
short term, we want
to just get at least the
LinkedIn users in those cities
that we're live.
And then step two
is let's get people
that don't have
LinkedIn accounts
and figure out how
to get them in.
JORGE CUETO: I think there are
a lot of professional networks
that are sort of more targeted.
I think there is
also one for doctors.
AMANDA BRADFORD: Yeah,
there's Doximity for doctors.
So we talked to them.
That's probably one we'll
do next year, is Doximity.
AUDIENCE: If you
can talk about how
you think about user
retention, because it seems
like if people are
really successful, then
they may just turn off
the platform very quickly.
And then on the other
hand, if they really
hate the experience,
they'll turn off quickly.
But there's, like, this sweet
spot of people who are maybe
a little bit frustrated
somehow but enjoy the platform
and will stay on it for a
long time and spend money.
So when people
churn, how do you--
AMANDA BRADFORD: Like,
good churn and bad
churn, yeah, so we call it
good churn and bad churn.
We keep our names
pretty simple here.
But, yeah, we are
excited about good churn.
I think that worrying
about good churn
is like worrying about someone
stealing your idea when
you're an entrepreneur.
That means your product is doing
the job that it was designed
to do, and hopefully
you can kind of
be smart enough to build a
business model around that,
to support that job
that it's doing.
So we don't worry
about good churn.
And I like to think that
every good churn is, like,
five new users.
In my head, I think of
that, because if they
tell their friends, or they say
it at the marriage ceremony,
or by just how viral
dating is in general,
people say where they met.
So if everybody did
good churn right away,
that would be an
amazing problem to have.
Bad churn is not good.
And bad churn typically happens
when people don't get matches.
And that is related
to either pickiness.
So they're saying
no to everyone.
They're really just not
happy with the selection.
Or they're very low-performing,
and everyone says no to them.
So that's sort of
the two use cases.
Or there's a bunch of
people in the middle that
are kind of, sort of picky,
not really, but also not really
happy, not getting
a ton of matches.
So, yeah, there's a lot of
different kind of experiences
people can have on the app.
And I think that's one of the
hardest parts of the product
management for it, is
that you kind of have--
we're just now doing kind
of cohorts and segments.
But, like, the older
people do churn faster.
It's almost like you have
so many different customer
segments to model that it
gets a little bit confusing.
So what we've started
to do is now just focus
on our target, our sweet spot.
All our revenue, our user
growth, our referrals
are all, like, 25 to 36
is sort of our sweet spot.
So we're really focusing
on in that cohort,
are we getting bad churn?
And we don't want bad
churn in that cohort.
But in the other cohorts,
we're kind of OK,
because they're a little bit
outside of our sweet spot.
So kind of just being
super focused on--
and if the people churned
out, why they did.
And you can kind of see.
The cool thing about just
having all the data is you
can literally see someone's
exact experience, who
they saw, if they liked them.
Maybe they saw a
terrible profile
and, like, disabled
their account.
You can actually
go and see that.
So you can kind of track back
what caused users to churn.
And it usually is, for
us, a lack of matches.
That's why we're so focused
on improving the algorithm,
because that's going to
increase retention a ton.
If you get one
good match a week,
you're going to stay on,
even if it's only one.
But if we're not giving
you one for three weeks,
you're going to churn.
So for us, that's optimizing
the algorithm better to make
sure you're not getting--
you know, you're
getting good matches,
and you're not getting them
all at once, at the beginning,
and burning through them.
So that's sort of the
other game theory part.
I think it gets into
ethics a little bit.
Do you give everyone their best
matches right at the beginning?
Or do you sprinkle in
different offerings
so that you always
are liking the guy we
think you should like?
When you only have a
hundred or a couple
of thousand people signed up
in a city, who do you let in?
Right now, we've
started moving into
an entirely, like, predictive,
model-based selection, where
rather than us being
like, oh, you'd
be good for the brand--
you went to a great school,
you have a great profile, like,
let's put you in-- instead,
we actually look and see.
Do their preferences
overlap with other people?
And are they going to
have a good time inside?
Because if the girl only
likes 60-year-old men,
and we don't have
any 60-year-old men,
she's not going to have
a good time at the party
is what we say.
So it's interesting
because you can
start to kind of almost
launch with people
that you are predicting
are going to find a match.
So now we're almost predicting
matches, like, weeks
in advance of when
we launch the cities.
And we're only
launching with people we
think are going to get a match.
So, yeah, it's a totally
different strategy
than kind of before when
it was very guesswork.
And like, oh, these
are people that we
think were going to match,
but it was very human.
And now it's
completely data-driven,
based on their pickiness.
Well, if it's a
brand-new user, it's
based on just users
that resemble them
and what they've
seen in the past.
And we can kind of predict
what the behavior is going
to be once we launch the city.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about how
you choose what's a good
education selectivity,
if it's level or school,
because I know in 2013,
actually, Laszlo came out
and said that GPA was totally
agnostic to Googler success.
So it actually wasn't
indicative of anything.
The only thing he said that
was in "The New York Times"
was conversation
and interviewing.
And so given that
a lot of schools--
you know, you can make
arguments that some schools
are better than others.
But also there's a lot of
industry-specific knowledge
that comes from
particular schools.
AMANDA BRADFORD: For sure, so
we value profession just as
high as education.
AUDIENCE: So is the education,
like, what school you go to
or what level of education?
AMANDA BRADFORD:
We're program-based.
AUDIENCE: So, what
metric do you--
AMANDA BRADFORD: Like
a medical school,
so if you went to any medical
school in the United States,
that's considered
highly selective
in our tiering system.
AUDIENCE: So for the
particular undergrad,
you're like, oh, this is an Ivy
League school, versus this is--
AMANDA BRADFORD: So we
have three categories.
We call a school highly
selective, selective,
or it's just not tagged.
AUDIENCE: I see.
So you mark every school.
AMANDA BRADFORD: And program,
so for instance, like you said,
a doctor, if you're
in a doctors program
at University of Alabama,
that is highly selective.
You're studying to
be a doctor, right?
So it's program-based.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, OK, so
that was my question,
was how do you approach
that algorithmically?
AMANDA BRADFORD:
Well, we haven't
done anything super cool yet.
But right now, it's sort
of in, like, V2 stage,
where we sort of have
the data set tagged.
But it's not very
international right now,
so we're kind of adding in
more international programs.
And now we're in
London and Toronto.
So we learned a lot
of, oh, we didn't have
this school in our database.
So now, we're kind
of crowdsourcing
a bunch of the schools
and the programs.
And everyone writes them
a little bit different
on LinkedIn, so
it's not perfect.
But we can look for the
word MD or something
to show that they are kind of
investing in higher education.
And that's sort of the way we're
trying to kind of proxy it.
And I like to think of the
education as it's less of a--
I think people use
it is as a proxy
for, like, I wouldn't
say ambition.
I guess the way people
I've seen use it--
I've actually watched different
people use the filters--
and it is definitely for
people with graduate degrees.
The only people
that care about it
are the ones with
graduate degrees.
And I think it is
because they tend
to want to find someone
that shares their values
and that is in their
kind of industry.
So we did an analysis on who
actually uses the education
filter.
And it's usually
people in their 30s
and with a graduate
degree, doctor, lawyer,
something like that.
But, yeah, it's
interesting to see, like,
who uses these and who doesn't.
It's pretty interesting.
We should write a book sometime.
But the good news is,
though, if anyone's
read "Dataclysm," which was kind
of the last big book written
about online dating, we want to
kind of do an update to that.
But the good news is a lot of
the kind of terrible trends he
talks about, which is still
true across the board in dating,
they are getting better.
People are getting
more open-minded.
People are getting less
racist on online dating.
heightist, less elitist.
We've noticed it in our data,
even in the past three years.
People are becoming more
open-minded on online dating.
And it's a shift
that takes time.
So I think as much as
we can be mad about it
and hate the space, I think
it is improving these products
using more authentication,
getting more information
about the user.
I think it is helping us as
a society kind of make better
matches for ourselves.
So I would disagree
with the point
that it's causing people
to be more elitist.
I actually think, because you're
able to see all of these people
that you weren't
able to see before
in your homogeneous
Google life or whatever--
my life, you know, I took
one bus back and forth.
So I didn't get out
of my comfort zone.
And a study just
came out actually,
that online dating is actually
widening people's preferences.
And also there's a lot
more interracial marriages
happening just because of the
surge of online dating, which
they are attributing it
100% to online dating.
So that just came out.
And I'll send you
guys to follow up.
But that just came out in, I
think, "The New York Times"
or something, about how online
dating is resulting in kind
of a more open-minded society.
JORGE CUETO: I'll do a
question from the Dory,
from someone who's watching
in the live stream.
"You keep using
the term singles,
but open relationships
and polyamory
are becoming more and
more prevalent nowadays."
Does the League explicitly
try to avoid such users?
It doesn't seem to
discriminate against singles
in open relationships
but does have a bias
against openly married.
What's your take?
AMANDA BRADFORD: Yeah,
it's a good question.
I think when we
launched, we wanted
to be really clear about
what the product was
and what the brand was,
what the offering was.
So it was for people looking for
long or serious relationships,
soulmates, life partners.
It wasn't for casual sex.
And it wasn't for a person in
an open relationship trying
to find another person
to add to their people.
So it was a very kind of
core focused-use case.
Like I said, I was
designing it for myself.
To me, that wasn't going to
help me solve my problem.
So I designed it to
speak very clearly
about why you should be there.
I think we've kicked
out a couple of people
that were married and using
it for open relationships.
And I think the way I
think about it is there are
a ton of dating apps out there.
And it's getting more and
more nice and fragmented
and use-case specific.
So I think that I
can even name some
that are designed for three-ways
or designed for polyamory.
So I think that
instead of trying
to be everything to
everyone, why don't we
just get really good at
the demographic we have
and assume that someone
else will kind of take
that opportunity, I guess?
One thing I've learned
in the last three years
is you can't go after
every opportunity.
You're going to burn
out, and I have.
So you have to make
hard decisions.
And I think for us, it's
like, I can't worry about the
over 40 year olds.
And I can't worry
about the polyamorous
and the open relationship
people because they're not
contributing meaningfully
to actually our core
business that we're building,
our core company that we're
building.
So it's like you have to support
users that are funding you.
And then let's build
them a product.
And then if we can
kind of get that right,
then there's a lot more products
and people to build for.
So I kind of think
of that as, like,
when we have an R&D
department, sure.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
AMANDA BRADFORD: Sure.
AUDIENCE: How do
you get started?
I heard you say you
got four people.
And how did you get those three
other people on board with you?
And it looks like LinkedIn is
kind of critical to this app.
And how did you get
partnership with them?
And were you worried?
Is it open API or
something like--
if they're going to
withdraw that at some point?
AMANDA BRADFORD: Yeah,
it's a good question.
The LinkedIn thing
is interesting, now
that they're bought by
Microsoft, especially.
But we were, like, the
first one to use them.
And they were like, what?
A dating site wants to use us?
I was like, you guys have the
best data set in the world.
Of course, I want to use it.
So we kind of got grandfathered
in because people were actually
creating LinkedIn
accounts to join
our app, which is really
high friction when
you're paying for a user.
You're like, what?
So we're giving them users in a
sense, because people are like,
oh.
I need a LinkedIn account.
I don't want to pay.
So I'll go create a LinkedIn
account and then authenticate.
So I think they saw that there's
clear benefit in new users.
So we kind of
positioned it that way,
as we'll be giving
you new leads.
And we're not going to do
anything spammy or anything
weird.
We're just literally
displaying the data.
But they actually have cut
off their API access now,
the public profile view.
So we actually are
grandfathered into, like,
a pretty nice little
moat, I guess.
We have some extra
API permissions.
Your other question was about--
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah,
the three other people.
AMANDA BRADFORD: Oh, starting?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMANDA BRADFORD: So, yeah,
the starting was funny.
This is why now we're
doing these small cities.
I'm having, like, flashbacks
to when I was in San Francisco
and literally going door to door
and knocking and being like,
do you know any single people?
Can you text them right now?
And I need, like, 200 more
people so we can launch.
So what I did is I set myself a
goal of, like, 300 guys and 300
girls.
And we actually built it
into the wait list screen,
a little progress bar of how
many more women and men were
needed to get to the 300,
which it was kind of overkill,
I guess, of a feature because
it was only pertinent from 0
to 300.
And then it was sort of
outdated at that point.
But it took a long time to get
from 0 to 300 in each gender
category.
But, yeah, that was sort of the
goal, was once we got to 300,
we were going to launch
and see if it worked.
And that's obviously a
very small number of users.
So that was also why there's
only three to five potentials
given every day, because
I was like, well,
how do we launch
this, because it was
in the era of unlimited swipes?
And Tinder was giving everybody
as many as you wanted.
So we actually kind
of stole, not stole,
I guess pulled a page out of
Coffee Meets Bagel and Hinge's
book because they were doing
the kind of daily batch thing.
And I was like, well,
let's do that and make it
more fun, like happy hour.
And so that's why we
give only three to five
a day, so that we don't have
to be concerned about supply
issues, especially upon launch,
because some of the people
were launching.
I think we only had, like,
100 people ready to show them.
And then we are kind
of betting that we'll
be acquiring more people.
And they'll be coming in.
And so you have
to kind of figure
out how much of an archive,
or I guess backlog,
you have to kind of create
first before you launch
so you know how many you need.
So we found that
it's about 300 guys
and 300 girls is sort
of the minimum you
need, because you have to assume
that, like, 70% might log in.
And then of the ones that
log in, some might be picky.
So you kind of want
to make sure that you
have enough people
that actually had
a good experience at the end
of that kind of first launch
experience.
AUDIENCE: OK, so the first
question kind of piggybacks off
what you just mentioned,
and the other one
is completely different.
So how did you guys originally
get to that number, 300,
for each?
AMANDA BRADFORD: It's
kind of random, I guess.
Yeah, I think a couple
of different ways.
We kind of triangulated it.
So one was that was
just the number I picked
for launching San Francisco.
So that was me being very,
I guess, you know, cursory.
And then the second piece
was we did this model that
predicts how many happy
people are going to be
in a cohort on a wait list.
So we can see in Indianapolis,
there's 438 people of the,
like, 2,000 that we predict will
have a good time in the party.
So it's a little bit
of how many people
do you need to make
sure there's going to be
a good amount of happy users.
So that's sort of
where that 300 comes
from because we found that
if there's at least 400
is about the right happy users.
So then you assume not
all of them log in.
And so that's where you get
to kind of about 300, 300.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool,
and question two
is you mentioned that you did
an incubator through the nights.
AMANDA BRADFORD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: After you
were working here?
AMANDA BRADFORD: Yeah,
it was with Google.
I was at the SF office there, so
it was easier to commit to it.
But it was Women 2.0 put it on.
But it was for men and women.
It was just called--
now I can't remember.
It was just called, like a--
I don't know-- innovation
program or something.
But, yeah, it was cool,
just because it got you
in the motion.
But it wasn't your day job.
Everyone had a day job.
So it was a little
bit less intense.
And you got to kind of try
your hand at it without having
a ton of pressure.
AUDIENCE: OK, because that
was the other question,
was how did you manage
doing that and working here.
AMANDA BRADFORD: Oh, yeah,
well, I didn't really--
no, I worked hard at Google.
So I just worked a lot.
That was one of the reasons
why I had relationship issues,
because I was working so hard.
So it all comes back, right?
It all comes back full circle.
But, yeah, I think I
just tried to balance it.
I did a lot of that
on the weekends.
That would be almost my whole
weekend, would be on that.
And then at nights, I
would work till 7:00
and then work on it
from 7:00 to 9:00
in, like, a conference room
here and just hammer it out.
So that's how I did the GMAT,
to study for the GMAT here, too,
but, yeah.
JORGE CUETO: We have time
for one more question.
AMANDA BRADFORD: [INAUDIBLE]
purple back there.
AUDIENCE: On business
school, two things
you learned in
business school that
were useful for starting
a startup, after two
years at Google, did
you feel like you
needed to go to business school
to leave and start a startup?
AMANDA BRADFORD: Yeah, it's
a really good question.
I think if you know you
want to start a startup,
and you get into a top-three
business school, you should go,
because it's going to help
the process of starting up.
It's worth the money, I guess.
If you think about
it just, like,
as a pure ROI-based argument,
the amount of amazing people
you can get mentored
by, the amount of access
to funding environment,
you're paying for opportunity.
You're paying for opportunity
to kind of be presented to you.
So I think if that's it.
But I think once you get out
of the, like, top one or two
or three programs,
then I think it
becomes a lot about
what are you going
to learn that is going to change
the trajectory of your career.
I guess a lot of our funding
came from connections
I made at Stanford.
So that's why I can't
with a straight face
say I didn't need to go.
But did I use anything I
learned from business school?
I feel like I knew
what I didn't know.
Because we studied
entrepreneurship
for, like, two years.
So you've heard enough horror
stories and terrible stories.
You kind of know that
you need to hire someone,
or you know you should
be doing this as a model.
Or you know you should be
doing more data analysis there.
So you kind of know your
blind spots a little bit.
So I think you can kind of run
your company better because you
have that knowledge.
But I don't think
it's, like, a huge--
besides the access to funding,
and obviously the network
that helped us launch
the League specifically,
because there's a lot of
Stanford people on it.
But, yeah, I don't know.
I guess I would say, if you know
you want to start a company,
and you get into a
place like Stanford,
they are born and bred
to put entrepreneurs out
into the world.
So they're very good at that,
and I felt very confident
coming out and
starting a company.
And I think that's hard
to value, that confidence
and the ability to--
especially as a single founder--
double entendre, I know.
But especially as
a single founder,
I think having that degree, even
though it's a little-- like,
I don't like credentials.
I don't care that
much about pedigree.
But I do think it helps you
just kind of walk into a room
and be like, yes.
I'm fundraising.
Yes, I'm doing this, and having
people take you seriously.
So I do think there's
something there
that you have to
give credit for.
But, I mean, it's an expensive
project, business school.
So I had a lot of sleepless
nights about it before I went.
JORGE CUETO: And
with that, time's up.
So thank you,
everyone, for coming.
And thank you, Amanda,
for being here with us.
AMANDA BRADFORD:
Yeah, it was so fun.
Great questions, guys.
[APPLAUSE]